one more drink one more
drink you know in the morning
for sure we gonna stink one more
round one more round
it's
this is what we do catch up for a few
we'll riff and talk some [ __ ] and then
we'll sleep till too
[Music]
we got tonight babe so why don't you
stay you're
you're in a seeger drinking mode yeah
hell yeah
love the silver bullet band you always
won every time you placed a bet
i see the rules man hollywood knights
come on oh
like a rock i mean he's one of those
guys you feel him like you you got the
windows down and you're driving with the
night air
going through the wind uh windows oh
there's nothing better than seaguar is
there
is there a better road song than turn
the page
oh yeah it's heavy duty it's like it's
like man emotion
as a guy you're like i can deal with
this i don't want [ __ ] boys to men i
want
i want something that's a little
masculine at least
it's so masculine and it's like you're
right it's like feelings that we're okay
feeling
yeah yeah exactly i mean [ __ ] those
lyrics are like
when you're driving 15 hours
you know it's like right it's like this
is we can complain about this it's
definitely like
you know yeah yeah yeah he's like ah the
hooker
died i had to figure it out put her in
the trunk
yeah it's like masculine sad [ __ ] you're
allowed to be cool with but
i how many times like in college where
like i got a girl over and she's like i
better go home
and it's getting late i'm like we got
tonight babe
why don't you stay and she's like all
right
like i might never see you again sister
it's romantic
yet so unromantic right right because
the honesty makes it right you're like
hey well i'm being honest
yeah he's not being like i love you he's
being like we got tonight
yes yes we'll never last this is not
there's nothing between us
but we're we're here tonight let's let's
make love let's make it happen
let's make it not much of a looker i
don't care for your personality skills
no but we're here and we're giving it
our best shot there
you go we got toast tonight
to tonight what are you drinking
well just at this club uh comedy in
texas
yeah i mean tay haas i got a good riff
off
on the audience i said uh wearing a mask
in texas is like wearing a helmet at a
skate park
you have to decide do i want to be
healthy or get called a [ __ ]
this is a goat cup they wouldn't let me
leave with a real cup so they gave me
this [ __ ]
special needs kids cup but um
i got you should be where you should be
wearing a helmet with that one
on the rocks oh yeah
exactly yeah margarita on the rocks
little salt love love a margarita man
that's
that's a that's a classic i like a salt
rim too you know there's nothing better
than a chili salt rim dude
oh good call good call so true i mean a
frozen margarita i feel like a a weirdo
drinking a slushie
give me the rocks give me the salt and
and go easy on the syrup
slushies are for rookies man yeah
yeah come on what is that you know or or
anything blue no offense black people i
know you love the blue
drinks and i used to bartend a little
there was always
blue bayous and whatnot electric
lemonade
yeah exactly horrible sex move by the
way
the electric lemonade um but yeah yeah
that's where you uh pee on somebody
while tasing them i don't know but
uh yeah any drink with slushy or frozen
like a fro
a pina colada's not bad but you got to
be on the beach
yeah i just prefer if i can if i can
have it like in this form i'm doing it
if i if i can have the easier way
it's it's for a kid it's a child move
exactly
ah come on when you i guess if you're on
the beach and you're and you're in
vacation i'm not going to give you
a hard time for it but i remember a tell
once i saw a towel on stage and
the guy was drinking a daiquiri and toad
looks and goes tough day
then in his special some guy knocks over
a daiquiri and it's just like red
you know rainbowy drink and he goes
somewhere a clown just died
that's just the weirdest obscure
reference but somehow it worked
it's also like that guy's so good he's
got multiple daiquiri jokes
just locked and loaded that's an
alcoholic
or a great comic either way
and you know what i i figured i just
shake it on the pod get a little shake
action going there
love it love it real drunk i just came
from i had a really good drink at this
uh
i was doing a show at a brazilian
restaurant and uh
yeah it was really fun and she made me
this drink it was like a spicy
grapefruit drink and i'm like hey man am
i
it's not my go-to but when in rome she
said this is this is what i recommend
and it was [ __ ] lovely i love that oh
what do you got a name i don't know what
the name was she said it quickly and i
couldn't she was very attractive so i
didn't catch the name
she was one of those like she was so
attractive that uh
but she was wearing the mask so really
like i just know that she has great eyes
right right exactly sometimes the mask
off
oh i love a bridge sometimes the mask
off will ruin a lady like
there was this woman in jersey once who
ran this comedy club i'm not gonna say
who it was and she had these beautiful
eyes and pretty hair and she took the
mask off and it was like
it was terrifying it was a two-face she
had crazy teeth she had
acne around the lips a little bit of a
stash she should be wearing that mask uh
in
2028
you hope that was you hope that was acne
around the lips mark i don't know i
don't know if there's just acne around
the lips
also it is it does worry me a little bit
like the uh
you just gotta take a chance it's it's
weird it's like you
yeah it's weird that like meeting
someone in person is now more risky than
meeting someone on a dating app
oh good point good do you know what i
mean i can't be like you lied to me
like i just assumed you were better yeah
yes
exactly your eyes were writing a check
your lips
couldn't cash this is terrible
so guys we had a little bit of a wi-fi
issue i think we're good again we're
sorry about that i think we were talking
about uh women
with masks and how it is it is more
risky
to to meet people in person than it is
on
dating apps because on dating apps
they're going to look more like the
picture than they do
you know half faced ah good point good
point yeah yeah
the mask helps a lot of people i mean
there's some bad lippage out there some
guys have a double chin so they go low
with the mask
a cleft palate maybe or a herpe you know
there's a couple
perks to the mask
people when if you have bad yeah but
they're suffering their bad breath with
that mask
but the if you have great eyes you're
you're winning life dude
i was insecure about my eyebrows growing
up so if i got like a big pair of
aviators i was feeling great
isn't that fascinating like everybody's
got their own secure insecurities
you'd be shocked what people like oh
that's why you wear turtlenecks because
you hate your neck
like you never know yeah for sure
and uh there you go uh
yeah man no we all got our [ __ ] i mean
that's you know
was there something you were insecure
about oh my well i got weird ears
my ears are connected uh i had horrible
teeth growing up i had braces for six
years i had a guess
six years my whole high school was
braces it was it was a nightmare
damn i never would have guessed that
they look fine
yeah they did a good job but my whole
early years was i was fat
i had [ __ ] you were not fat i was fat
as hell i mean i was
i was chubby too oh really yeah i i
i had i'd say i had breasts for a period
yeah yeah
same same i worked him off by the time i
would have enjoyed them but i uh i had
breasts
no i i definitely had a chubby face for
sure
yes same same i had a triple chin i had
the gap i was a bed wetter i had the
braces i had horrible dandruff i had
dumb hair
that
head and shoulders does nothing for me
it's not good
sell some blue does help sell some blue
is not bad i use
some [ __ ] called t gel which is like
medical
and then remember you remember that old
commercial
uh sell some blue where it's like the
baseball player and it's the third base
coach i think and he just keeps
scratching
just keeps scratching he thinks he's
giving him a sign that was a pretty good
that's not bad that's not good that's
that's just me sounding old
that's when advertisers had [ __ ]
balls
i remember un remember sure sure sure
unchew unshoe unsure they had the b.o oh
i remember the like uh it was old spice
or something but it was the guy who
would just like
he's on the pga tour or something he
just he cheers yes i want him everyone
collapses
right that's fun stuff that's not bad
yeah they would be like that's offensive
to people with
with bad body odor right right they
can't help it it's like oh shut the [ __ ]
up we all have to have bad body odor you
got to put the deodorant on god damn it
but yeah i think women are nice about it
women are nice
where like if you smell like oh you
might need you might right
yeah women are great and thank god for
ladies because
if they got b.o you just assume she's
homeless
or or or on drugs but if a guy has bo
it's like hey he's working hard or he
skipped a shower day
they hit the gym i didn't go to the gym
you must have been in the gym
i wasn't i wasn't in the gym and i'll go
so far as i've heard a few gals say they
don't mind a little b.o
yeah i think i think people like on a
primal level maybe
yes the natural scent you get like a
little but i like the same one goes i
like when women
you know like i like when they smell it
like something nice but i also
when you get that real smell it's kind
of hot oh
yeah yeah i don't mind like if the
vagina schumer used to always say when
the vagina smells like soup
that's when you know it's the real deal
and i completely agree
got a good clam chowder going a nice
that's what they want to hear you like
lentil all right i'm down
split p
[Laughter]
wow vagina really is a split p that's
fine yeah it really is
yes we really nailed it yeah man i do
like a natural scent there's something
about a natural scent that is pretty hot
hey we're all animals at the end we can
fight it all day long with our
cumber buns and tennis shoes and
condominiums but we're animals baby
we are animals you see dogs sniff
another dog's butt and you laugh but
then you're like i'm looking at
at the person walking the dog's butt
like we're doing
we're all doing the same [ __ ] we're
doing the same [ __ ] and a dog's ass
is nothing but information a dog's ass
is like a tinder profile you just it's
like a file cabinet
of what's he eating or what's she eating
where's she been what is she like
is she sick is she healthy
it really is it's interesting new uh
yeah i mean
it's cool that dogs can just sniff a
butt and that's kind of like that's
their move because like we have to do so
much
i know to get to the ass sniffing it
takes a couple days it takes a while
yeah yeah dogging it right in there you
know but
animals are very problematic when you
break them down i mean the
violence the rape the the gender roles
animals are still going with gender
roles oh tell me my [ __ ]
corgi just got me to it it's terrible
no it's you're right the animal rape
it's like it's insane that we don't even
think about it we're like that's
that there's no consent no no it's true
and like they'll [ __ ] their own kids
sometimes or they eat their own kids
crazy yeah yeah so [ __ ] are you
watching the woody allen dock at all or
no
i can't do it i keep hearing it either
it's so mean
you know we did it it's like the thing
is like you know we did it so why do i
want to see it
right right and i've just heard horrible
things about her how she's twisted
and all this [ __ ] so i i can't watch
it's too isn't it too heavy
isn't it weird that hbo don't they still
stream as movies
probably i mean you can't deny those
movies look if if roethlisberger makes a
touchdown
you still get the points yeah but if
roethlisberger
molested a uh like a a daughter like it
yeah it's [ __ ] bad is it molesting if
she marries him i feel like
like it's no but that's not the one he's
in trouble for oh
it's it's the it's dylan it's not i mean
the suny and by the way the sunni
defense is not a great defense
look it's definitely weird you know uh i
hate my
family so i don't understand it but yeah
yeah
the whole thing's i don't like that [ __ ]
like i never watched the michael jackson
dock
i did uh it's rough
i mean you're like look in both cases
best case scenario he just wanted to
have sleepovers with kids
yeah which is not great not great
not great but uh i don't know it's just
weird that people are like hey you made
a pedophile joke i'm like you watch that
movie with popcorn
and like your friends isn't that weird
don't isn't it amazing like just how we
consume
the this content like there'll be a true
crime and she was never seen again i'm
stuffing my face with goobers oh
i'm not [ __ ] yeah exactly ted bundy's
like a you know uh
got he's got more netflix specials than
than
bill burr i mean it's craze all over the
place everybody loves
five partners yeah what's that five
parter yeah and all the girls like he's
so cute he's so cute i'm like what the
[ __ ] going on
well you know it's crazy because woody
allen did you know it's like
he wrote a book and it's just basically
about his childhood in brooklyn but
which is like if sandusky wrote a book
only about football
cool there's other [ __ ] we'd like to
hear about right right
we'd like to hear from your side because
all he writes is like a very brief like
this is [ __ ] this is not true
and then there's like behavioral
psychiatrists on the other side we're
like this
is not looking good yeah
yeah you know wayne fetterman's woody
allen joke it's one of the best jokes no
hit me i love because
he goes woody allen's my hero all these
years and still married to the same
daughter
that's great that's a great little
misdirect great clean
well you know pedophilia joke basically
uh yeah let me let me go back to the
margarita for one second
sure slushy do you ever get a brain
freeze
i always hear people oh i got a brain
freeze yeah
what is that i've never had one in my
life oh you it's literally what it
sounds like you just
it's like a headache it's like you're
just like ah it goes away and it's
like you never get it from like i've
never gotten it i guess when you're a
kid you get it from ice cream and stuff
yeah
i think you're just downing it too
quickly and it's cold it's
talk about a [ __ ] first world problem
[Laughter]
right right yeah that's you know anyone
yeah i mean [ __ ]
i do love a margarita i do love
any of those like tequila based cocktail
and i love that
what i love about margaritas are just
the options like you never
you could just throw any fruit in there
that's true
watermelon mango i like a spicy mango
one you throw that
that's my go-to if i'm doing a margarita
somewhere i'm [ __ ]
that's even a jalapeno margarita which
is also delightful
what's better than jalapeno and tequila
it's great it's great
you get the little kick of the tequila
little kick of the spice everybody wins
and you get a real spicy butthole the
next day it really like
you really feel it i mean that's see i
drink a lot of coffee so it's like when
you combine
that with like you know i like hot sauce
on my food then you combine
then you combine the spicy cocktail
you're like oh you're [ __ ]
you're just like you're not gonna be
able to do you can't travel far from
home
no no no and your dog is gonna smell it
when he sniffs your butt
thank god dogs can't drink they'd be
that'd be a whole different butt sniff
that would be [ __ ] great though if
your dog could just get [ __ ]
did you ever have the friend who would
like blow weed on their dog yeah
i hate it i felt so bad for the dog like
yeah this is speaking of consent
your dog doesn't want to be high right
now don't turn your [ __ ] dog into a
loser too man
so true and your dog's paranoid he's
like is that the mailman what the [ __ ]
ah he's freaking out
i mean looking at him like do you even
like me dude
you even [ __ ] like me right right
like i gotta stop chasing that cat i'm a
dick
uh but hey you mentioned brazilian i
wanted to get this joke in best thing
about a brazilian restaurant
no pubes all right i can't put pubes in
the food because they don't have any
brazilian wax that's a nice little
that's a nice little throw away right
there i like that
i'll tweet it tomorrow you go to brazil
that's your [ __ ] opener
yes yeah all right well i gotta get on
my agent book me
what do they call it in brazil when you
get a [ __ ] wax in they call it a wax
just a wax yeah yeah i guess so it's
like chinese food in china it's just
food
yeah i wonder what the i think it's a
different type in uh
different type of wax museum there
just figurines made of hair
that's funny i never got the wax museum
yeah it's not for me it's just kind of
like it's a tourist trap
yeah here's the one thing i like about
the wax museum
when the celebrity will [ __ ] with people
oh that's good a few years ago carmelo
anthony just did it where he's you know
from the knicks he just kind of chilled
frozen and then scared people and like
that's [ __ ] that makes a whole trip
that's that's the best yeah that's
amazing and fun for the guy
too he gets to scare the [ __ ] out of
people and then they go from biggest
fear of their life to elated it's him
the best one is too it's like there's
certain people get a picture with you're
like you think you're fooling anyone
you think you're coming back to like
dude you met saddam hussein
holy [ __ ] right right you met j-lo
and brad pitt in one outing holy hell
holy [ __ ] and with the same weird uh you
know
subtle backdrop that's so strange yeah
yeah and uh i never got any of those
like
i went to la when i was in high school
it was a fun trip with my dad
and we did the homes for the stars
and you just get in like a shitty bus
with no no
top on it and you're like oh that's uh
candace bergen's garage
like oh great we did we did a similar
thing with my family when i was a kid
we went to la and we did we did all that
kind of stuff but i remember
the highlight my dad somehow got us like
tickets to watch it wasn't the actual
taping but it was like a run-through of
frasier
so we watched him like working it out
and it was crazy it's like
it's like kelsey grammer and david hyde
pierce like going over notes and just
like
they're incredible live dude they're
like because they're like they're like
stage guys
so they're just so [ __ ] good like
you know they're people that are like
whatever frasier first off it's a great
show obviously
yeah great underrated but the acting on
that show is insane
yeah these are theater pros but i saw
they're bringing it back and
it's like only kelsey grammer what
they're rebooting that they're rebooting
it for paramount plus
but uh
it's a new viacom thing it's like cbs
all access is now paramount plus so they
have a big
library all the [ __ ] that via comes
running to the ground you know comedy
central
bt uh mtv [ __ ] that defined our
generation
now young people are like huh
exactly exactly it's like the cosby show
we're like this is one of the best
sitcoms ever ah that's ruined
yeah we don't talk about it anymore but
yeah yeah all our [ __ ] woody allen bill
cosby it's all [ __ ]
a lot a lot of people are they're
dropping uh cosm i mean woody allen's
really like the top
of like it's weird like i feel like
early 2000s he was still going strong he
had like vicky christina barcelona match
point we're like yeah
you're pulling big talent with these
movies you're getting like javier bardem
he's gonna just go to europe where no
one gives a [ __ ]
like polanski did yeah yeah
yeah he did the pianist that was that
him yeah
yeah that was a that that was killer
that won best picture even after the
scandal which is
that that'll never happen again how
funny is it the oscars gave him like a
like a lifetime achievement award in
like 2003 or something and then like
they're like kevin hart had a homophobic
tweet i know i know
so much as j this guy you need to
apologize for a tweet
meanwhile roman polanski you're a one
you're a genius
you're so good ass plowing a gal a
child in a hot tub ah we could look past
it
but this guy said lansky did some dark
[ __ ] dark
dark [ __ ] but if we're just talking
about the work chinatown's one of the
best
movies of all time great movie great
masterpiece
terrible terrible [ __ ] he's done
terrible [ __ ]
like i said you know ray rice he still
gets those numbers
more he's been he's long retired oh is
he [ __ ] i gotta keep up
i'm off i want to do i want to do a
thing i always want to do a bit about
like how
he hits a woman in the elevator
and you keep seeing it on youtube and
there'd be ads before it and it's like
someone's profiting off this [ __ ] yeah
hey that went viral i mean
it's a hit it's it's good people like it
literally
yeah so it sucks that that's his
highlight reel now it went from like you
know all these great
great moments in the football to uh just
an elevator
six seconds in an elevator you know much
harder it is
to uh to accomplish what he did
than to just be a [ __ ] domestic prick
you know what i mean like
i know to to reach what they reach and
then to just be a piece of [ __ ]
like what a [ __ ] letdown i mean you
could say the same for jared fogle
i mean this guy was fat as [ __ ] and then
you know
made a name for himself losing weight
and then became a millionaire as the
subway guy and then boom
child porn yeah he lost weight and he
was carrying even more weight than we
ever
on his shoulders and and yeah he fit a
lot of kids in those pants
i knew subway wasn't to be trusted when
i tried their avocado spread
that was [ __ ] this ain't avocado
they're really they were slumming it
subway is falling
harder than woody allen i mean they
really [ __ ] they were they had a
moment where it was like we're healthy
and we [ __ ] believed them
we bought it hook line and sinker give
me the crab give me the tuna
give me the tofu sub foot long
was there a tofu sub oh yeah oh yeah
that was a fake meat or whatever you
call it
i mean look i'm not gonna i thought it
tasted pretty good but it was one of the
things where i'm like i just ate 12
inches of bread and steak and you're
telling me
being healthy seinfeld had a bit about
it he's like you're telling me this guy
lost 100 pounds on an
all hoagie diet you know it's a great
bit but
hoagie is the perfect word perfect word
perfect word is anyone's buying this for
a second
what does he have a duncan heinz iv is
that next whatever
that's why i love jerry because he's got
a billion dollars and he's
furious and you know it's [ __ ] real
that's what i love about seinfeld
and he's furious about subway or or
there's
cheese and a pizza crust what the hell
is going on out there everybody else is
like oh the war in iraq and
uh you know this and that he's like ah
my pillow i was always more of a quiznos
guy man
what i thought quiznos had some solid
yeah
some good sandwiches if i'm at an
airport and i see a quiznos i'm happy
really i never got into it i mean i
guess they beat
subway in a technicality but uh yeah it
never got into it they toasted it right
that was the big difference
a subway toasted i just thought it was
just better i don't know why i was
better but
blimpy was like the one that was like
you're like the cracked out cousin
you're like
you know you know every every
presidential candidate's got that like
that brother or cousin that's on like
crack or something
that was that was blimpy where you're
like is blimpy okay
right and also when you're
when you're famous subway's famous for
losing weight and then you're called
blimpy
it doesn't really look good for the uh
the pr
yeah why not lord ass while you're at it
really uh right yeah they really uh
blimpy and the blimping was even good it
was like so this is
i don't know we might be drunk it's
brought to you by blue chew
get more confidence in the bedroom blue
chew offers the same active ingredients
as viagra and cialis but it's chewable
so if you don't like swallowing pills
this is for you works fast take a day or
night and you'll save a lot of money
compared to those name brands but blue
chew is the best thing on the internet
it's an online prescription service
that means no doctor's office and
waiting or waiting in line and you don't
want to wait in line
right because that's [ __ ] weird uh
talk to a like talk to a licensed
medical professional
to get your prescription all online
everything blue chew
you know and and uh it's in a discreet
package so it's not even like you know
you have to be like this is my these are
my dick pills you're good
uh yes here here i just want to riff on
blue chew i'm a big fan i used to keep
one in my you know that weird pocket in
the jeans that small
pocket that you put drugs or
paraphernalia
or pills whatever it is i used to keep
one in there just in case i i bumped
into a gal and i was nervous
and works quick every time goes down
easy
tastes solid tastes good and uh
it never fails it's the best and there's
no side effects no nothing
i'm a fan i'm gonna order some i'm
excited right
this is a special offer just for you
drunks visit bluechu.com and get your
first shipment free when you use the
promo code drunk
five dollar shipping again that's
bluetooth b-l-u-e-shoe.com
promo code drunk and you get to try it
for free
yes i would get on that guys definitely
definitely just do it today get it over
with knock it out it couldn't be easier
so get that dick hard baby
do you have a go-to if you i know you're
not a fast food guy and i'm not really
huge but is there like a go-to for one
if you're on the road i love fast food i
just try not to but i love
taco bell i'm a wendy's guy if we're
talking burger
i think wendy's is like i mean if we're
like spicy chicken sandwich i don't
think he could really
wendy's is great wendy's is great they
got the dollar menu when i was a janitor
i used to hit that dot it was like
you could mix it up get the chili one
day get the baked potato
who else is a [ __ ] baked potato baked
potato is good
uh i'm thinking if there's any i mean
yeah i love taco bell too
definitely it's [ __ ] good i remember
opening opening for bert kreicher one
night
years ago it's probably [ __ ] like
nine years ago now or something
wow i mean maybe eight i don't know it's
a long time ago but we're
on the road and we're in um we're in
some bar and birch drunk and he just
goes
someone buy taco bell and somebody's
like i'll go and he just hands him like
a hundred and the guy just comes back
like
a 100 tacos it was like a taco for a
dollar yeah
so we're just shit-faced stuffing our
faces in some bar by the way that serve
food we're just being [ __ ] drunk
that's not the bird i know
wow that's so funny you say that because
i did a uh
uh maybe they didn't serve food maybe i
don't know but
who knows but i did a gig with ari bert
and a couple other guys i can't remember
who sean patton we all went out and
skied
and we got really drunk after the show
and went to del taco
and we ordered craig it was that
annoying [ __ ] where we're all drunk in a
van yelling at the lady behind the
the in the drive-through like well what
the hell oh give me that
give it get some fries you know that
whole thing and she got it all
and bert just pulled a hundred dollar
bill out and paid for everything yeah
he's
i mean dude he's so generous oh yeah
i mean he he really is so generous uh
that's awesome
he he really is i dude i did a outright
dublin
and it was like one of the best shows
ever and i have a photo in my phone
i'll post it to the patreon harry if you
can do that but at one point we all got
[ __ ] faced we blacked out i don't
remember anything but i looked at my
phone the next day and i have a picture
of bert
carrying about ah 12 pizza boxes like in
a cartoon like they're
they're waving whoa and he's just
holding him on the sidewalk giving him
out to fans
i got i got the photo he is like a fun
guy like
here's the thing with alcohol drinkers
who drink in excess
i would no i wouldn't call a bird an
alcoholic but i think like he does drink
an excess
he is definitely an alcoholic you think
yeah but you know he's functioning
maybe that's why i don't think of him
like i think of an alcoholic as someone
who's like kind of a loser you're right
maybe he does go on
but the thing about bird is like he's
fun like
there's a type of drunk that is so fun
yeah and maybe that's what keeps you in
the game
you know what i mean like good point
maybe it's i mean the guy who gets
shit-faced and says the n-word
at an office party it's like he couldn't
handle it he ain't drinking anymore
maybe that saved him down the road right
yeah i mean
but that's true that's a good point but
bert really
is so fun i mean the fun drunk
it's really important because there are
people who still drink and you're like
[ __ ] this guy's here i know i know
there's the angry drunk there's the mean
drunk there's the blackout
yeah you're right you gotta really hone
your drinking ability like
i like to drink and i i gotta say i'm
gonna i'm the best drunk driver
this side of the mississippi such a
hilarious thing to brag about
i know that's that's one of my skills
sadly i'm like
i'm i'm i'm it's a skill you've honed it
it was like known in new orleans like
we'd all be shit-faced we had a
designated driver i'd kick him out of
the car and i go i'm driving this thing
and uh yeah just if that if there was a
merit badge for drinking and driving i
would be i'd be loaded up
well you're definitely loaded up brother
i mean i remember list and i
on a gig joe list and i
i want to say this is like more than
that maybe like
11 years ago we did that casino run and
joe
i didn't realize how drunk joe was when
he joe drank oh
and so joe so i can't drive i'm a
terrible driver he would get fewer
on the gig it's like i did like 30
minutes of driving he did 30 hours
you know like throughout the week he was
furious at me i told him i'm bad at
making turns and he goes
do you realize that's a big part of
driving you [ __ ] idiot
he was so mad at me yeah so we're in
we're in a casino it was a [ __ ] hell
gig whatever and like joe was so funny
it was like
literally so this was the gig uh
we're in milwaukee it's during the
playoffs the casino's under construction
so they moved the band cheap trick from
the music room
to the comedy club they moved joe and
myself
to the bar during the playoffs that the
brewers are playing in
so we're like hey can you turn the game
off
because and they're like no it's the
playoffs and we're like
well can we do shorter sets and the guy
goes not if you want to get paid so
we're like
oh it's one of those gigs so joe
is [ __ ] killing me because he goes on
stage and
the cardinals are kicking the brewer's
ass and joe just starts cheering so hard
for the cardinals like
[ __ ] [ __ ] milwaukee [ __ ] the brewers
he's commentating on their
just demise just yeah infuriating and i
have to go on after him because we kept
swapping
the order oh god and they
did not like me either so oh was he he
was bombing
oh yeah but he was hilarious but he's
bombing because they're [ __ ]
furious and i [ __ ] bombed worse you
know
so you try to do a set yeah
yeah my mistake but yeah i mean we ended
up watching cheap trick
afterwards and was hilarious watching
joey i mean they were awesome man
i want you to want me surrender i'm like
this is [ __ ] fun man i'm i'm into it
and uh anyway then we go to the tables
yeah you know joe immediately loses a
shitload of money he finds me he goes
how are you doing i'm like yeah you know
i'm you know
i'm there he goes tell me oh my god i'm
up a little bit he's like [ __ ] you he's
furious
and uh kids are going let's go back we
drive back
and uh i didn't know he was [ __ ]
wasted he
the next day he goes how do we get home
i'm like oh you [ __ ]
oh yeah you drove me home in a blackout
yeah
well i'll tell you he was in a blackout
far better than i ever was
well you know these guys that grew up in
boston they're drinking like since
they're 13
yeah you got to get good at it but i
mean who is good who's got that great
bit of how a blackout is just time
travel
you know you oh yeah you're waiting like
who's got that great bid
75 is david tell especially if it's
about blacking out
but yeah i call it time travel there it
is
that's it yeah you wake up you're like
oh all that all that driving is done i
parked the car i got out
i i came inside i had a sandwich not i
don't remember any of it i [ __ ] myself
you wake up you're still not assistant
manager you're banging the girl on the
violin
right she's [ __ ] but those titties
ain't [ __ ] yeah that's a classic
one of the best albums of all time folks
if you haven't checked out skanks for
the memories
the best album of all time for any
comedy album skanks for the memories by
david tell
us you think the best i think it's the
best comedy album of all time
wow what tops it i mean i think uh
killing them softly is up there i think
that's a special it's not an album oh
okay good point good point cause we're
going killing them softly is phenomenal
i love chappelle i mean like as a
special that's
tops it's it's like that i kind of
i love rocks yeah i
i love you know chewed up is great uh
back in town by carl and yeah we can do
this all night all
day baby yeah all day even live in
concert with prior i think it's one of
the best specials oh my god
i'll say yeah i'll say that for sure i
love
um i mean the closing on live is a
sunset strip when pryor's doing jim
brown he's doing a little bit about
freebasing is like the funniest
well you're like man i hope no one has
to live through this [ __ ] but like if
they do thank god
they can make it this funny you know
probably yes
totally oh yeah i mean just to come out
it's on netflix now by the way live in
concert which is so great
i showed it to my girl she's she's
younger and she liked it she hates
anything she's got the phone in her face
you know she's a genius so he comes out
he's like riffing on the room he's doing
a special in the 70s riffing on the room
riffing on the guy in the front row
talking about the seats and black people
stealing the white people's seats
it's all rift it's unbelievable he's
just he's just like a natural
well the comfort is not the comfort just
shows you like this dude was born to be
this like it's not someone who's like
here's my set it's someone who's like
look at this [ __ ] like look at this
guy this guy's coming in late you know
what i mean
like that comfort level and then he has
the jokes too so it's like right
right i mean he's got everything uh
prior
you know he's got everything he's got
every tool
yeah he's so [ __ ] funny the word on
the street is he did two sets and the
first one
bomb big bomb and the second one he was
just like
[ __ ] it let's just let's just go balls
to the wall and that's why it was so
good
that's what you ever heard the mitch
hedberg comedy central half hour story
45 and just bombed the whole time and
they sweetened it
yes and then it was happening no one
could tell well when the jokes are that
good and you sweeten it no one can tell
right right but that's why at one point
he's sitting on the stage like this
this sucks i'm [ __ ] but they sweetened
it and the [ __ ]
the public loved it it's one of the best
ever
oh yeah the glasses you're like who is
this guy he was so different he was so
weird he was so out
outside the box it was great i mean rice
is great when you want 2 000 of
something
yeah it's so [ __ ] good i i mean all
those old
i love it i'm sick of following my
dreams i'm just going to ask them where
they're going and catch up with them
later
i'm against picketing but i don't know
how to show it i mean come on that's
like
groucho marx level [ __ ] yeah it really
is you're right it's like
old-timey comedy but no one can that's
what it is he's disguising it it's kind
of like the big lebowski it's like
we took an old-timey detective movie but
we threw in a a burnout so you guys
can't tell
right well this is dead the sleuth
is a guy who's just a [ __ ] he's just
a
hippie like a bird kind of that was
hedberg i mean he's doing like
the stephen wright type uh you know
one-liner comedy you know i guess he
would do a little more than that because
he would he would tag it up but
but yeah it's the best i mean hedberg's
the best he's so
funny he's the best because his delivery
system was so different you know he's
like i got long hair i got
[ __ ] rose-colored glasses on i'm a
heroin addict
and then that rhythm you could say
anything in that rhythm that cadence
and it was innocent the comedy you could
tell there was a darkness
about him but the comedy was so innocent
and sweet and like good point there's
something pretty cool about that too
like the juxtaposition of this like you
know there's a darkness living there but
then
combined with you know and he needed
your love
like like he he would kill on
letterman's like my mom loves those
applause breaks
i'm aware that joke is stupid like he
was so real he was so
vulnerable are we two of the last comics
that really give a [ __ ] about late night
sets
are we like like we are the we are like
the last
of the comedians who are like really
care like i love late night sets still
i haven't seen mike vecchio he was on
tonight's show last night
i'm excited to watch how sad we're a
bunch of nerds no no no he's the is the
best
if you guys haven't heard mike vecchio's
album the worst kind of thoughtful
get on that right now on spotify itunes
wherever you get your [ __ ]
mike vecchio is the funniest dude like
literally the and talk about jokes per
minute punch lines per minute just
killer rider beast like the crowd
can't catch up they're laughing so hard
and i think he won album of the year
with that album or was that deservedly
so it's one of the best ever i mean he
he has one of my favorite jokes of all
time where he said i signed up to be a
detective online
and they just took my money and i
thought either i just got ripped off
or this is my first case ah that's
that's so bro beautiful that's a
beautiful joke
yeah he's got a great joke he's like i
bought condoms in a vending machine
or i saw a guy buying condoms on a
vending machine and they didn't come out
so he had to shake it
he's like i don't know that guy should
have a baby
something like that i butchered it but
yeah he's a killer
he has so many where you're just like
[ __ ] yeah
yeah i love it but his comedy makes me
so happy too he's such a [ __ ]
great comic give me a give me a peeve
dude oh all right all right
i'm going all over the place with this
peeve cause uh
i love it though i love i love i feel
like our peeves are getting more focused
okay okay well i feel like i've been
[ __ ] on people with their
with their peeves and annoyed with
everybody so i'm turning a peeve onto
myself
that i do whoa yes i'm putting i'm
putting up a mirror
i gotta tell you man it's been a weird
week i don't know what's going on
i try to be an efficient guy i try to
take care of my [ __ ]
i left my keys in my apartment i had to
call a locksmith just because i left my
i didn't put my keys in my pocket i
walked out did a bunch of shows came
back
had to call a locksmith damn so i'm just
sick of forgetting [ __ ] i flew here
today
forgot my headphones so i had to go buy
headphones so now i'm
i'm 300 in deep for the locksmith and
then
i had to buy headphones and i'm 30 bucks
shy with that so it's like
i'm [ __ ] myself because i'm not
concentrating i got to get my [ __ ]
together
you know what i think it's it's a sign
of stress because yeah
i'm i'm very forgetful right now like i
i did it the other day like
it's funny i did a set
little airpod thing the container thing
oh yes
yes so i think it's just
you know we forget [ __ ] we just we're
stressed man it's it's
this is a stressful time we're all
living in and we're like we're almost at
the end of i think
the worst of this [ __ ] i hope but uh
i think we're all losing our [ __ ] i
don't even think like you should hold
yourself
i mean the keys thing sucks i i think
about that all the time like i
i thought i lost them tonight and i it
turned out i just put them in like a
jacket pocket instead of a jean pocket
but like that's the stress where you're
like i could have forgot them and now
i'm locked out it's it's that
that's what we're living in man yeah
yeah totally and it
you just i hear my dad's voice like come
on
son get your [ __ ] together you're an
adult now blah blah blah and i'm like
the key is such a [ __ ] because it's it's
just
one little thing it's almost like a
passport like you forget your passport
it's just like a piece of paper but you
got to go all the way back and get it
you know and it's just such a little the
key is this big and it ruins your whole
[ __ ] night the key is a [ __ ] is
really the yeah
and i i'm with you man it's so tough
like i have friends who are telling me
to invest in cryptocurrency and then
they break down
how you like have to engrave it into a a
metal thing to remember the code so you
don't get it stolen
then you put that in like a safety
deposit box and i'm like i'd rather not
have that much money i'm good
this is stressing me out even just
listening to it and i know people
say i'm a [ __ ] idiot i just i'm so
disorganized
with everything but my jokes that's
literally
guess what i never forget a little
[ __ ] i got two joke pads in my back
pocket
i got two i never forget those pieces of
paper
i forget other [ __ ] constantly i'm with
you i got a stack of notes right here
i never forget it it's the only thing i
remember
yeah and i i have forgotten it before
and you want to kill yourself like you
ever lost a notepad
holy [ __ ] i don't like losing a child
it really is i don't like the the phone
as a like because then you start typing
then you're like this this
is not the same i like writing because
it it starts
it starts entering your brain you start
yes
and it flows out of you with a pen with
typing i'm like
i don't need more time on my phone
either i'm trying to avoid the phone if
i get a point
yeah then you open it now you're on
twitter and now you're on insta now
you're on grindr
it gets me every time uh oh and this is
a more relatable pet peeve
that was just me i got to get my [ __ ]
together but i hate when people ask you
a question
and then they ask you another question
before you finish the answer
like i'll give you an example i go uh
they're just not listening
yeah yeah and you're like did you care
about the other one or what are we doing
here like
what what city you live in
i live in new york what kind of car are
you driving
uh i don't drive a car see that movie
and you're like ow
did you care about the question or not
don't ask me another question before i'm
done with this [ __ ] what is this
answer the [ __ ] lightning round what
do you think i know it's crazy
drives me nuts so i got a lot of that's
oh yeah
those interactions are tough cause
you're just like not only do you not
care about me
we lack a rhythm so i don't feel
comfortable that's so true
it's terrible that's a huge peeve of
mine i
i like that with you i feel like we i've
never felt like i it's a weird thing to
say to
a friend but like i don't feel
uncomfortable with you ever i never
like right you know what i mean though
like i feel like i've known you for so
long but it's kind of just i'm also a
little drunk
i look listen mark you're hanging on me
come on just say it you want to make it
out
look this might be these negroni's
talking but
no i just never i don't like being
around people that
it's the most obvious sentence ever but
when they just [ __ ] start
when they start like cutting you off or
chiming in a weird time
it throws your rhythm off and you start
your heart kind of starts jumping a
little yes yes
exactly exactly now you're on edge
you're like am i being interviewed and
i guess you didn't care about that other
question and are you just asking me [ __ ]
so i start talking and i'm feeling dead
air or do you actually give a [ __ ]
that's what it is i think i think it's
it's nerves that that person might be
nervous so that they're
maybe they have like a social anxiety so
they're but now you're giving me social
anxiety
right right you're making it worse yeah
the feeling of the dead air is
yeah that's what podcasting is all about
brother i know
i don't mind daddy i'd rather dead air
than than phony
questions and [ __ ] chit chat you
call it dead air i call it [ __ ]
peace and quiet yeah i mean this is
silence
when you're with another person is it
can be wonderful when you're just
comfortable with the other person
you ever just with your partner and
you're just sitting there and it's quiet
and you're like
looking at the sun and you're like this
is cool man oh
that's the best that's when you know
you're with somebody you can actually be
with
when you can actually have a moment of
sight like i drove uh i drove on a road
trip once with a with a girlfriend and
we talked barely at all and then when we
did talk it was like deep and
thoughtful and weird and then we just go
back to silence
it was great i love the yeah you know
it's it's important man i
i got a lot of peeves man i got a lot of
names
well people uh
who people who are like pull you ever do
this ever talking to someone to like oh
you like this i'm like yeah they're like
well you like that and i say yeah they
go which one do you like better
uh i'm like well i don't know they're
different they're like all right well
you know say you have to choose yeah
i'm like do i work for [ __ ] buzzfeed
why do i have to like are we doing a
list like why can't i just like
things i don't like the the people that
pressure you into ranking things
yes yes i think that's another nerves
thing or they think this is
this is good bar convo like we got a
real topic going buddy
shut up let's just talk
the top 10 well i have to be like you
know it's it really has like
that energy of like quick for the next
slide if you're if you're ready
i don't like these websites that are
like
the 50 top things and you have to click
for each one i'm like
i'm never going to use your website
never never if it's a website where
they're like the top 50 episodes and
it's one page i'm like
cool yeah yeah but they know they they
know what they're doing they know they
got you by the balls and you got to
click over oh now there's an ad
oh now there's another oh it refreshed
me to somewhere else and you're like god
damn it i just want to get the top 48
over here
yeah it's the [ __ ] worst yeah so i'm
with you on that
basketball football go hey what do we
what is this that one's easy for me you
know which one i like
that's true that's true i do love
basketball are you ginger marianne
i don't know i haven't seen the show in
30 years oh my god those are like
how depressed you have to be to be like
which succession character
are you click i know i know you're like
anyone's excited
mark i'm a tom dude i'm a tom dude
i know how much i like tom right right
what celebrity look like
shia labeouf with aids i got it i'm
moving on
i'm any any celebrity with aids that's
just my
that's it anytime i get a compliment
they're like but with aids
i'm like okay yeah yeah yeah what is it
michael phelps with aids pete sampras
with aids
uh i got pete sanders as a ketologist
because i curly hair and thick eyebrows
i think right
but he was a cool one again people would
say to me like an insult i'm like oh
he's banging
the the hot t-shirt from billy madison
so uh i'll take it
he's married to her they're married yeah
wow good for him veronica vaughn dude
even that name is hot veronica that was
her name in the movie that was oh
okay okay about to say jesus you gotta
be high that's a lot of pressure
not a kid veronica vaughn
[Music]
that movie it's like uh that movie's
like like like pizza it's just always
you can just you can just have it like
all right i'll i'll call it hot whatever
i love him it's so dumb and great it's
you know he made it because he loved
back to school like that's definitely
why he made it don't you think because
he's such a big rodney guy
that's true that's true but just the
balls it takes
or the the secureness it takes to go
stop looking at me swan
i would do that on my own and be like oh
i'll never show anybody this but he's
like he's got a full
crew lights gaffer grip you know
a cast a director and he's doing that on
camera i could never do that i love it
it's it's funny man and uh back to
school to me is like
i'd still probably like what do you know
what are your top five comedy movies
ever
uh you see where where where uh where
where what do you call it the
connoisseurs
so like everybody's seen billy madison
and old school but we've seen
all the [ __ ] i wouldn't call myself a
connoisseur
i just think i like a lot of old
comedies well i don't think a lot of
people have seen back to school i don't
think it's it's a big
it's i think so it's never really
brought up as like you know it's animal
house caddyshack coming to america
trading places
i think back to school is funnier than
like oh coming to america is in the
conversation with baxter yeah that's a
great one
i eddie murphy i go beverly hills cop is
like
right head in head with i love trading
places too
but like i just [ __ ] love beverly
hills cop because he's so young and so
full of energy and so [ __ ] funny in
it like he's so likable
it's that big smile the laugh
he's so good in it but it's also
it's basically an action film that just
happens to be kind of funny because
eddie murphy's in it
so but dude judge reinhold's funny john
ashton is such a great straight man like
dude i mean i think eddie murphy should
have got an oscar nomination for nutty
professor man
oh my god he played six roles and he
killed all of them
tell me that's not better than at least
for the nominees
that's a good point what he did with
that movie
like is it a perfect movie like it's a
good comedy i think like what
i don't like people get nominated for
like okay movies all the time when
they're great
eddie murphy [ __ ] is incredible in
that movie
incredible i mean he played the mom he
played the dead
it was insane and he he played the uh
oh that was that was dave chappelle but
[ __ ] chappelle rules in that movie oh
he kills it uh [ __ ] be shopping i
mean he started that whole
trend that was just the character he did
he plays sherman and buddy love so he's
like
so he plays this fat lovable loser and
he also plays
the cool like [ __ ] prince
yeah i'm like dude eddie murphy's range
is insane
and here here's a here's a sneaker
here's a sucker punch
bowfinger is amazing he's amazing in
bowfinger nobody brings it up
bowfinger's a really good movie really
good really he's amazing plays this
nerdy guy
with braces it's incredible it's a
complete transformation
you're right he's incredible he should
have an oscar i mean
he got [ __ ] because dream girls was
kind of like they're like all right well
finally we're taking you seriously and i
think he lost like alan arkin or someone
who
he's great but it's like right dude
eddie murphy's singing dude
he's got like a [ __ ] perm like just
give him the oscar the guy
[ __ ] rules even in coming to america
the barbershop scene he's the old jewish
guy
and the other guy unbelievable but they
weren't like the problem with the
academy awards and it's
there's so many obviously but they don't
take comedy seriously
no no never and like you gotta get they
don't give any love to
any comedic actors unless they do some
[ __ ]
dramatic movie that is not as good as
the comedy they're doing
yeah that's so true well i guess you
just it's hard to take comedy seriously
i mean they're they're being
funny it's not serious but then if a
guy's got it
but it's got to be like a dramatic actor
in a comedy if it's like dustin hoffman
and tootsie they'll look at it
but if it's but if it's a comedic actor
they just don't respect them
i'll tell you what's up there with that
is uh robert downey jr and tropic
thunder
unreal i mean he was a black guy it was
unbelievable
that's one that like he is a serious
actor that they respect so that's one
that like could have happened
yeah you know but that would be fun
later
like oh you're gonna cancel everybody
with the blackface but you're giving it
to that guy
that would be a fun thing to throw at
him later but uh
they didn't he didn't win so yeah they
just don't really give it unless you're
like wow
if anthony hopkins does a comedy they're
like we'll bite but if it's [ __ ]
you know will ferrell who's you know
obviously a genius
jim carrey nothing did carrie get
nominated for anything ever
i mean he got nominated for the majestic
which was like a [ __ ] movie
and then truman show i think got
nominated
truman show is good that's good it's
good good movie
but yeah you're right no comedy who else
is a great
who else deserves a kind i mean jim
carrey in the mask is [ __ ] insane
like it's not like a perfect movie but
he's insane
it's cheesy but he's incredible in it i
know he really is
damn damn
sorry rob williams one for uh goodwill
hunting goodwill hunting
he's incredible in that though yeah he
really is
stop [ __ ] with me sean don't [ __ ]
with me
people hate on that movie man i love
that movie
yeah joe hates it yeah so does rondon
they just think it's them sucking each
other
off i think it's a great i love it great
movie
it's like man i just i think i just like
people [ __ ] on ben affleck i think he's
[ __ ] great man i
i think i do i think the town is like
one of the best movies in the last 20
years
i love the town love sounds incredible
it's [ __ ] incredible
it's incredible yeah like affleck's a
[ __ ] i'm like he's a great filmmaker
what are you talking about
i know i mean wasn't jeremy renner in
that was that him
yeah it was [ __ ] incredible he's a
killer actor he's up there with tom
hardy i think
dude when they do that scene when he's
like i need to go to a place i need to
beat the share of these people and you
can't ask any questions they go he's
just like
where do you want me to go like like
that type of loyalty that's [ __ ]
incredible the town is so i think it's
on netflix right now it's so
[ __ ] good maybe it's on the amazon
the stream not one of the streamers
i think it's amazon i feel like boston
had a run
where it was like all right this is the
last bastion of like cool american white
guys
you know because the white guy got weird
and everything and it was like american
history x it was like what the hell is
going on with these honkies but i feel
like
boston had a little bit of edge and they
had the the accent
so they kind of norton should have been
our de niro he just didn't get the
the roles but he is ed norden i remember
when american history acts as a kid like
obviously it hasn't aged like perfectly
it's like very melodramatic
but he's incredible like he is
undeniable
he says that [ __ ] him up by the way
that movie that movie
yeah [ __ ] i heard he's a dick
i love him so much though really oh i
think he's like
the best are you kidding me eddie right
fight club
birdman uh american history x yeah a
primal fear
that was like his breakthrough that was
incredible that was his firs that was
introducing ed norton he got another
dude people versus larry flynn
directed keeping the faith solid rom-com
cass
meet cass milo's foreman in the movie
which i [ __ ] love him for
like because he just loved him wow
i mean ed norton [ __ ] rules dude
that's amazing red dragon
never saw that one it was one of those
uh hannibal sequels it wasn't bad but
ed norton does a good job he's a leading
man in it it's any and he pulls it
off he's [ __ ] great
all right all right what are the pet
peeves you got we went off on a movie
tear there
i got a thing this is on me too i think
a little bit but i get bummed when
someone does something shitty to me
and then they apologize immediately and
they don't even give me like
45 seconds to be annoyed oh interesting
give me an example
like all right i was playing ball in my
part in the park with my buddy the other
day
and it was game point and i took him to
the rack hard which is probably my
mistake in a friendly game on game point
but he just hip checked me and you know
i went down it's not that bad but you
know i got a little
oh i got a boo boo got a little [ __ ]
cuts nothing bad but you know
yeah uh but he just [ __ ] hip-checked
me and i went down i'm just like all
right dude
i was like [ __ ] you it was like he i was
like you could have hurt me
yeah yeah i'm not a kid sure
and and he goes oh and i'm sorry i'm
like
but like i'm like you threw me to the
ground right
but i wasn't like but that but then
you're like all right what am i i'm
gonna be staying mad at a [ __ ] friend
like who gives a [ __ ]
right right well see that's a tough one
because i feel like it'd be weirder if
he didn't say sorry immediately
fair enough but i don't want to i don't
want to not
yes and but no you're probably right i
admit this one's on me i mean like
i think i wanted to [ __ ] about it for a
couple more minutes i get it i get it
yeah because now you have to console him
because yo it's all right man it's cool
no biggie man no i couldn't i
could have [ __ ] ended my [ __ ] you
know yeah i did my [ __ ] elbow if i
went down a little harder
right no i know it's not that bad a cut
but i was like i was like i was bleeding
a decent amount it was
pretty annoying again um let's see what
else
um oh i gotta
i wrote this down speaking of cheesy uh
so i finished cobra kai because of you
ah
and i bet you haven't watched one
[ __ ] rick and morty i'll say that too
i haven't but i'm on season four of peep
show so i'm getting there
are you loving it i'm loving it it's so
great being the lady watching
dude it's the best it only gets better
it makes me happy
i i've always forgiven season one i was
like okay okay then season two i'm on
the floor
it's one of the great shows of all
it's in my top five comedies ever no
doubt well it's it's
low brow but still smart like the the
the main guy's obsession with war is so
funny like is he's always like i'm
i'm storming the castle in prague or
whatever the [ __ ] you know i love that
[ __ ]
he's mackie he's macky he looks just
like mackie i was saying that the other
day
it's perfect it's really funny and like
and they'll go
crazy and weird like uh all right kid
who would you rather suck off me or him
and he's like i'm not saying then
cut to like the kid's all weird he's
like what happened he sucked me off
i'm [ __ ] super hands yes yes
that guy rules yeah peep show if you
guys haven't seen it it's on amazon and
it's [ __ ]
it's the best give it a minute it's i
hate when people say that about shows
but like i promise like if you just give
it a minute it'll be your favorite
comedy and
margaret only gets better dude oh i
can't wait olivia coleman dude
oh yeah oh yeah it's great and there's a
lot of people in it the
one [ __ ] was in flea bag oh it's olivia
coleman
oh okay there you go also a great show
by the way fleabag's great
she's so good i mean every time she
looks at him she just looks so upset
just like the acting of her just looking
when that when they're going skydiving
when they're going bungee jumping i mean
i mean it's [ __ ]
incredible yeah yeah yeah so good i love
every girl he's the best character by
the way the the nerdy guy he's like
she's the one
yeah i mean i kind of love him equally
mark and jez but like super hands makes
me laugh the hardest probably because
he's just
[ __ ] yeah so i've been watching cobra
kai and like dude
it's so cheesy like it's cheesy to the
point that i'm like
this dialogue is trash like it's just
bad
dialogue i don't like ralph macchio's
character
no he's a smug and i guess that's part
of the plan part of it
like it's believable that that kid would
grow up to be
a [ __ ] dude like that yep yep i
love william zabcon the show
you're supposed to love him he's the
protagonist it's from the bully's
angle it's great he's a great actor
he is he really is he's got chops there
are scenes where i'm like
this is kind of heavy like the show the
the
premise it's so funny like kids just
obsessed with karate
like the idea that they're just like all
about like you'll have a realization
like
you know i'm yeah you know i'm done
living in the past
you know it's okay to think about the
past but to live in the past it's
pathetic and the next scene is like
his sensei from high school like you're
[ __ ] dead
i know i know it's it's they it feels so
dramatic and shakespearean they're in a
strip mall and like in a
[ __ ] karate dojo and
it's the end of the world all of a
sudden there's he's [ __ ] teaching 13
year olds and it's
it's so dramatic it's also hilarious
where they'll just like trash someone's
house
and the next scene they don't even
acknowledge it i'm like right i see
someone's home
yeah i know i know and then you're like
there's a weird love scene
and then you're like am i into this girl
is she 11 what am i doing here
there's a lot going on in that show it's
basically a kid's show
i know what you mean you're like looking
up actresses ages just to make sure
you're not a creep
you're like she's 25. i'm good all right
that's [ __ ] good she has tits she
doesn't
what's the difference of ages here
what's going on yeah
it's tough but brother is great in it
oh dude breaders and dana dude there's
two standard comics
the two guys who work in ralph macchio
shots shop
are funny comics man yeah yeah i love it
and they're good they're good actors but
uh but there's a reason this show
it's wildly popular like it got to
number one on netflix for a while and i
think
it's just it's so cheesy it's so over
the top but it's
there's something to it where it's like
this protagonist
or uh underdog thing i don't know it
hits home for some reason
you know what it is it's a guy who's
down on his luck who's made mistakes
who's doing his best and that's just so
relatable especially when it's a guy
who is familiar i mean yeah first off
shout out to william zabka is the bad
guy in back to school
that's right and the karate kid he was
like the hot
80s kid yep but [ __ ] man like
i feel like i don't know what his story
is because i feel like he didn't work a
lot for the last couple decades or maybe
you know three decades what happened but
well he got typecast as the boy he's the
bullying something else too he's the
bullying
karate kid back to school and then
something else there's a third one and
it's the same
blonde guy you know buff bully guy
and he just got typecasted and he was so
that guy that he couldn't do anything
else they're like we're not gonna book
you as the
the lead in the rom-com you're the bully
and he just couldn't get work and then
he quit the biz
it's funny think about if he was like
young now he'd probably be in the
[ __ ] avengers or something
so fickle you know he really uh
he's really terrific and he's so good in
the in the scenes that are kind of
nuanced you know and complex where he'll
like
he's an [ __ ] but he's actually trying
i think that's why
people love it i think it's like that's
such a relatable character
because we all know someone like that
and i think we all feel that way
yes yes and this is maybe a little maybe
i'm reaching here
but in a time of like chance canceling
and all that and there's no really
forgiveness anymore if somebody [ __ ] up
they're out
we're watching this guy who [ __ ] up he
was the bad guy and now he's kind of the
underdog good guy
and i think that's fun to see we're
seeing that like someone is not what we
think right
it's kind of cool and even if they are
what they think they're kind of not what
we think
you know right right we're all flawed
we're all insecure
and then you see like he cares like he
[ __ ] up with his kid but he is trying
with his other kid
it's weird how addictive this show it
goes down
like it goes down like like potato chips
or something right
that's just it's just easy yeah i
shouldn't have another one but [ __ ]
i'm doing it
it's basically a soap opera and you hear
ralph macchio [ __ ] about zabka and
you're like he's got a point and then
you hear zavka [ __ ] about macho you're
like
he's kind of right so then you're kind
of seeing things from both sides which
almost gets kind of political like the
left and the right whose side am i on oh
that's a good point that's a good point
so that it feels like there's some
parallels here that's a great point
machio is a smug liberal yeah and
yeah and and then zab is kind of like a
republican who's like kind of in the
middle
he's trumpy but he's also not trump
because he kind of has
uh he has like more heart he's kind of
like
he does like trump would never be like
uh
[ __ ] i [ __ ] up that's true i shouldn't
say trumpy i should say
but he's kind of like almost mega duty
where some guy's like hey that's you're
you're
assuming my gender he's like shut up get
only on the surface and that's the
that's
right machio is genuinely smug i mean
he's like a [ __ ] dude
who's culturally like think of you knew
this dude in real life he's a white dude
who's culturally appropriating japanese
culture
you're the most annoying human being you
have a hot wife you never [ __ ]
because you're busy teaching children
karate as a second job
and you're running your [ __ ] car
business into the ground
you're a [ __ ] clown i know because
you just hung up on this bully from high
school you dweeb
his wife's walking around in like
[ __ ] a bra and a track jacket and
you're like
bang your wife dude i know i know take a
breather but if the ego
kicks in and he can't let the guy win
and he can't let the other guy win
and yeah it's uh it's it's got layers i
gotta say
no it's fun it's a fun show for sure and
i and i and i i love the kid miguel
that kid's a great actress he's great
he's he's like got the peter parker
thing going where you're like i'm
rooting for this kid for sure
totally totally he's down on his luck
he's poor but he's got a heart of gold
yeah
he's adorable i love it i love it i'm a
great wreck
great wreck all right i'm so glad i'm so
glad you're in
i mean it's look is it like great
writing god no but it's [ __ ]
fun it's it's it's like to be honest i
think like some of the dialogue i'm like
squirming i'm like ugh i know the same
way
but it's also cheesy it's kind of fun to
squirm it's almost like when you're
eating a piece of cake you're like guys
it's so bad for me
and i love it i'm loving every second of
this icing
put it on my tits yeah it's good
it's fun the old man sensei martin
it's like hilarious like it is you know
i'm glad i'm glad you're watching peep
show that makes me happy and i'll get to
rick and morty don't you
don't you worry i'm coming i got a boy
salacious on it and
he's into it he loves it he's pushing me
on it now
all right this is all we have now this
is all we have now i know but
thank god art exists this is why art is
so great look at all these
hours we need at home and we gotta have
art and it's out there we get to consume
it
but it's just coming back i'm heading to
it again soon so i'm i'm excited
and i'm gonna i'm gonna hit it hard i'm
hell yeah
time to get back at it yes yes stand up
is uh
it's our bread and butter so it's gonna
be fun to get back man
hey hey folks we are also brought to you
by my
bookie march is here and that could only
mean one thing the craziest college
basketball tournament around baby that's
all
trademarked it's madness sorry takes
place in march you get it folks well
that's a big ass tournament and it's
finally here and my bookie is the way to
get it on the action
you got to do my bookie i know people
who have won
thousands on this thing you sit at home
yeah you go
nuts you win money you can't lose you
get to watch a couple of
sports balls and points racked up and uh
wacky athletes making millions and now
it's your turn to make some money
shoot your shot score big non-stop
action with my bookie bracket contest
you got a chance to win 10 large folks
only one buck to enter you hear that
one clam gets you in the door and select
winners from
63 tournament games that's how it
doesn't matter whether you're filling
out multiple brackets
betting the national championship winner
or simply looking for a player and game
props my bookies got you covered sign up
today
at mybookie.ag and use promo code drunk
to secure a deposit bonus
up to 1 000 smackers that's promo code
drunk to claim your first deposit bonus
college ball nba nhl no matter what the
sport no matter the minute
from tip off to buzzer my bookie puts
the action in your hands
with in-game live betting bet anything
anytime anywhere with my bookie
get on it folks and win some casheesh
well what do you got for rex speaking of
rex
i dude i got like nothing my wreck was
kind of weird this was my wreck
and it was stupid i updated my my bar at
home because i've been drinking out of a
funny bone glass the last few weeks
yeah i got some nice little scotch
glasses that is nice
i like it and i got a little shaker
going on i got some pint glasses i just
my wreck is i'm spending so much time at
home
let me update the home good call
so that was kind of my wreck this week i
like those glasses they got a hard
they got a lot of thick a thick bottom
oh dude a heavy bottom
man yes holy [ __ ]
yeah i'm with you when you can slam it
down and it doesn't break
it's it's nice and like man i got a nice
buzz on a kind of a stressful week so
it's just nice to kind of just chill
right now and just relax
you know good good all right let me
throw a weird wreck at you well i flew
here and forgot my headphones of course
so i couldn't listen to any podcasts
which i
i love and need but what do you listen
to for pods usually on the flight
uh i go all over the place like
sometimes i'll see who's doing what and
i'll just listen to a
a singular episode of a guy i like or a
gal i like
but you know you know me i like uh
gladwell and
freakonomics and a couple other ones but
i watched the bruce lee dock on the
plane it was pretty scary
yeah it's great pretty great yeah he's a
special guy man he really
totally you know what i love about him
is that
um he refused to be type cast as like a
stereotype
and he and you know he cost himself work
but he also
yeah it's incredible he's an incredible
guy uh
i know i don't feel like we talk about
like the you know we never talk about
the asian discrimination or the chinese
discrimination really
doesn't really come up you know it's
just like jew and black and
whatever trans but hey don't sleep on
the chinese bigotry
he really was a badass and you know to
risk it all when he was already a star
in asia and and come here the fact that
he died so young
32 i remember watching that uh
you know with someone else and she was
just like
i i had no idea this was coming she
didn't know he died so young
i mean he had so much ahead of him it's
just so tragic
he could have done so much more enter
the dragon just showcased
yes the charisma he had i mean i
remember like what a cool movie that
jim kelly was so cool and it was just a
badass movie
i know kareem abdul-jabbar is fun in
that it's just so crazy he's not in that
one which one is he's in another one
he's not
dragging okay but kareem was boys with
him kareem yeah
pay him for lessons which i'm like how
[ __ ] cool is it korean jabar might be
the coolest [ __ ] dude
i know i know al lual cinder
yeah played for the lakers was
a martial artist wrote wrote for
veronica mars
it was in the writer's room he does
everything dude he's like a jack of all
trades
if you ever read he does like op-eds and
they're so well-written he's such an
intelligent guy
wow he's one of the and he's the nba
scoring champ
yeah on and he's seven one seven foot
one
what a guy such he's such a legend is he
still around
yeah yeah he's around okay okay because
tall guys tend to not age well
wow i mean i'm hoping that changes
yeah well yeah i'm not talking about 7-1
like that's freaking nature [ __ ]
well bill russell's still alive he's
like 86 so oh okay
all right no kareem is the is the
coolest man
such a cool dude cool dude but yeah good
movie but i want to direct this
because i always do docs so i'm throwing
out this movie if you if you've seen it
i hope if you haven't you got to watch
it
captain fantastic i've never even heard
of it
oh my god it's this underrated movie
it's viggo mortensen
his i don't want to give it away but his
wife dies so he just says [ __ ]
civilization
he takes his kids they move to the woods
and live in the woods they hunt
they mild build a hut and a house and
read every night and build a fire
it's so amazing and then they have to go
into town to go to the wife's funeral
and it's it's they have their their the
kids are young so they've not
learned how to live in a society in a
city and
it really it's an eye-opener captain
fantastic it's on netflix check it out
i love viggo mortensen so good the movie
it makes you think cause you're like
maybe it is nice to live in the woods
maybe society is gross and capitalism
and
and fast food and all that [ __ ] and then
you see them in the woods and they're
like
they need medicine and they need a
teacher
and they need uh social skills and all
that [ __ ] so it's like which one is
better it's fascinating
wow yeah i mean it's uh
i've never heard it i'll give it i'll
give it a check out man
i've been uh just watching feel good
[ __ ] like what you said like uh
kobe kobakai i've been just re-watching
south park episodes
it's just putting me in a [ __ ] happy
place it's so silly and they have the
new vaccination episode which i'm gonna
watch
after this and there's so many great i
mean south park just
i mean that's talking about like
greatest movies of all time that
celebrate movies that's on my list for
sure
it's up there i mean talk about like
with comedy taking a hit with like i
don't know people getting upset you
can't say this
that is animated so they are doing the
like top-notch
balls to the wall commentary that no one
else can do
yeah they're kind of uncancelable
they've kind of just
they've kind of almost been
grandfathered in because they've been
around since before these [ __ ] dumb
rules applied
right and they just have never given a
[ __ ] and never
they're just so smart that they
literally go after
everyone that it's made them and it's
also like
i think the mob's gone after them enough
where they're just like we don't
we don't care yeah we're good
they truly don't and they've made
boatloads of money for the
for the comedy central i mean they
probably kept him on the air at some
points
and like i heard george clooney tried to
get on they were like sure
they wrote him as a dog and he just
barks because they're like well we don't
need you
but we'll have you on you know but he's
in the movie
okay he's in the movie but if you're
good you're good like
you i don't care how dirty you're
offensive if it's brilliant it's
brilliant
and let the man let the men work i heard
trey parker in an interview say they
asked if
they had any bad interactions with
celebrities and at the oscars he said
because they both wore dresses to the
oscars and they were on acid
and apparently jlo just walked up to him
and just
pushed him
which i think is like kind of like a
halfway like flirt
like you got me and being oh silly i
don't think she was like really pissed
but like they did a whole episode about
oh they did a whole episode where they
just painted her as the biggest [ __ ]
it's so good i mean dude they've
just gone after everybody that's the
point they've gone after everybody how
are you really mad you know
r kelly alec baldwin no they'll take
anybody
they don't give a [ __ ] they're so good
um
so that's another if i'm gonna do
another wreck that's give it it's on hbo
max
every [ __ ] season get on it man um
give me a joke dude
all right i got a couple joke ideas but
uh we're we're pushing the time limit
here so
this is this has been done already right
i tweeted it and they got a bunch of
retweets but then people were like i
think that's a jim jeffries joke that
somebody else said it was a stan hope
joke so i gotta run it by you uh-oh
uh you know like people get mad when
when
when a not like a caucasian plays a
native american
or people get mad when a a
regular what do you call it a biological
woman plays a trans woman you know you
can't do that anymore but
what about the fact that hot actors and
actresses are playing
ugly people like monster or uh
you know whatever it is has that been
done
they're appropriating ugly i think i
thought tom mccaffrey had a bit like
that
i could be wrong i'm a little buzzed uh
thinking a bit about like um
huh i think tom mccaffrey might had a
bit where it's like
ugly people were like can i play the
role they're like no we're just going to
take uh brad pitt and make him really
ugly
or something like that i don't know i
would just just message jim i'm sure
he's
you know uh i don't know him that well
i gotta ask him i don't know all right
you ask him but
maybe i'll just give it a goog i don't
know if it's give it a goog i don't know
i
i'm i worry that one sounds like it
might have been it's [ __ ] funny
oh thanks but yeah i feel like if two
people got that and then you said tom so
that's already three
three people i've heard had it so i'm
going to drop it
um i mean good people to be on parallel
thought with doug stan
jim jeffries all right let me let me try
it let me try a real one then
yeah all right is this anything and this
is
this is out there so bear with me here
but homosexuality is interesting because
okay you're a hetero guy you like [ __ ]
you gotta go out and get [ __ ] you gotta
meet a gal
buy a drink tell a story be charming but
if you like
dick as a gay guy you own one
isn't that interesting like the thing
you like is on your body
you know and then then you get the whole
angle of like
i'm not into dick but i like my own
so i've given millions of hand jobs but
only to me
so i'm kind of gay for me i hate your
dick but i like my dick
i really want a ps5 well you already
have a controller you know
like uh yes yeah i like that about how
the thing you want you had an old i love
you a bit i love an older bit where
you'd say uh
like how gays keep jews want to
they want their race to live on they
want to live on they must be jealous of
gay people you know they can't even
procreate
but they keep popping up yeah you know
yeah that's a great bit
oh i think i think of uh
i think of so they want dick but they
have dick they have the
it's like being addicted to coke and
your body has you you make coke
or or some some other analogy
yeah it's almost like your kids your
dick is like your children because you
love yours but you hate that guy's kids
i think it's fascinating because it's
like
it's almost like
i know it's a weird idea no it's an
interesting premise that's why
it's not easily crackable right away
right right it's like
uh
you have a dick but you want another
dick and you want a different dick
you want a different dick every now and
then you don't want yeah i mean it's
like
your dick like yeah we we've seen this a
different dick
and you don't want a dick that looks
just like yours either aha
right right if you work at a pizza shop
every you know you can have pizza sure
but every now and then you want some
some different pizza you want a deep
dish or a
or you know a calzone or something from
another place i like that i like that
you look at thin crust
you want to go out for some deep dish
there you go
okay that's that's better if you're
eating at mcdonald's
if you're working at mcdonald's you
don't want to eat at mcdonald's
yeah but you will
you will if you have to but if someone
says let's go to wendy's
you accept the invitation well if you're
gay you're not into wendy
but i see what you're saying
but if you're if you're gay you still
it's just fascinating to me that you
have the part that you
are attracted to that it is interesting
yeah you have
you have what you want it's just you
don't want yourself you don't want
yourself
you'll settle for it when you're alone
at night rubbing one out in the shower
or whatever
is it kind of like cooking at home
versus eating out
now we're getting somewhere that's
interesting
you're like [ __ ] i mean like i guess
everything's closed i can
i can make myself some eggs right right
and and us heteros we eat out every
night
double entendre there you got it i i
like
i like the idea i like the angle of
eating at home versus eating now because
i think that's a clear jack off [ __ ]
someone else
right that's a good angle i think that's
a great premise
what about the premise the second part
about how i i have a dick
uh and i'll i'm not gay but i like my
own
is that is that a separate thing
like i'm gay for me yeah it's
interesting like we'll jerk our dicks
off but we won't suck our own dicks
you would i tried i gotta i could
i licked it once i've licked all right
there we go well you do just to know you
could do it but i'm not gonna wanna
i don't wanna it's not really my thing
but like if a guy
[ __ ] on you you'd [ __ ] you'd fight
him but you've [ __ ] on yourself
it's my own juice exactly exactly
i think it's the difference is it's
consentable jizz
right right right it's just i mean i'm
agreeing on
guys also never i'd never touch a dick
and you're like you touch one every
night
i don't know maybe the thing the thing
is
jerking off is almost like doing the
dishes it's maintenance in the
it's maintenance at home you gotta do it
just to make sure [ __ ]
stays okay right
so you don't shoot up a school
you got to do it have you you know the
dudes that don't jack off enough to like
the dudes that are just like
like that dude hit on her way too hard
right right yeah that's true
all right dude that dude hasn't had a
home-cooked meal in ages
yes home-cooked meal it's made with love
i don't i like that angle more than the
i jerk a dick off i'm not you know uh
i'm not gay but i took a dick off every
i i feel like that's
not it's just not as interesting the
first part is more interesting to me
all right all right well that works for
me
um i have an angle about so i have a
couple jokes about my biological dad
first of all i have a thing about like
how
you know he's like the type of old
school guy who like
wants the baseball game on which is
convenient because it's like you can't
bring up real [ __ ]
when the game is on you can't right it
can't be like there's a two-two count
you're like speaking of 22
uh those were the amount of years i
didn't hear from you and
you know or like yeah like
so that was like oh there's a uh there's
a there's a there's a shot to the gap
where was he on that player like
where was he all right uh
i don't know also you basically as
a as your son or as your as his son
you've been benched
you know it's like hey yeah can i get in
the varsity dad i mean i'd like to play
can i
can you play me jesus christ so that was
one part the other part was like so i
have a half brother i've never met so i
at one point i asked him i said you know
we kind of look alike and i just said
you know i'm curious i'd like to i'd
like to meet him and he said uh
you know i i floated it past him and he
didn't really bite
i was like man that was like the most
corporate way to describe me never
getting to meet a bloody relative
you know what i mean it's like that's
hilarious
we ran it by the people upstairs and
they didn't really
uh didn't really work for them yeah
they weren't on it i don't know what
happened yeah those are
those are two different two different
bits but all surrounding the dad
the biological dad i think there's a lot
there with the baseball thing too
yeah i was thinking about a lot about
like yankees games because you uh
you go to a yankees game what do they
always play right after the
the last pitch of throne is uh sinatra
start spreading the news i'm leaving
today more than i got
yeah and not to mention what is it what
is the cliche thing to do with your dad
and son
play catch these guys got baseball on tv
you couldn't throw me a ball
hmm yeah it's interesting baseball is so
dude just you don't talk about real [ __ ]
during sports that's why guys like that
[ __ ] you talk about
who you hooked up with you never like
this is what you like at dinner you
might
have like a like i need to talk to you
about something that [ __ ] doesn't happen
during the game
right right it's also
something too with like hey i'm trying
to come home dad i'm trying to
you know like wave me in i'm trying to
get home
i don't know it's so true though sports
the whole point of sports is to just
distract
and escape and yet he's got the game on
24 7 so yeah you can't bond
right that's interesting
and then yeah then you gotta you just
finally have a half brother it's like
jesus christ
turn the game off and introduce us this
game is ruining us
it's uh yeah it's funny i remember going
there like and then but sometimes you're
mad the game isn't on sometimes you're
like this is too real for me
without that so like i would like you
know his wife will be like come over
the game will be on i'm like all right
i'll come over and then you go there
there's no game on i'm like yeah i was
i was told there'd be a buffer you know
what i mean like where's the where's the
buffer
that's great that's great where's the
buffer
yeah for for father's day you get them
the the full sports package so you're
like all right never again
we're never gonna have an awkward moment
we got you mlb
uh dmob package yeah you never talk
about anything you're watching chinese
games at one point you're like oh yeah
oh that was close
you know the season was over but thank
god these guys are still going
before we get out should we read an
email from the from the patreon
just so you guys know that our patreon
is kicking guys remember uh
patreon.com we might be drunk pod you
get another episode
so yes you can email us you know uh we
might be drunk
uh pod gmail.com yes
and yeah i mean [ __ ] it's it's it's a
good time i'll read you some
send us a joke a pet peeve a drink a
recommendation whatever you want i'll
read on right now from uh
sign ups jolly you know it would be
awesome if you guys actually throw
suggestions on how to deal with a pet
peeve
or to act around the person that
triggers the pet peeve but anyway
wow sounds like already a pet peeve but
anyway here's a good one
people that that hummus around the house
for no
remember guessing hum around the house
instead of hummus
just working on humming a song like
every day in the kitchen
this gets to my nerves for some reason
if you tell a guy not to do something
they damn sure will so that won't work
so what do you do
wow this person seems a little angry
yeah one day
it came out and the person he responded
with
what you don't like when i'm happy and
i'm thinking no be happy all you want
just don't be annoying
anyhoo i love this bit you guys do on
pet peeves keep it up
but you probably uh start throwing slick
ideas on how to deal with it rather than
being super agreeable with each other
which is also awesome right on piece let
me know how you feel about humming
uh when the episode airs yeah what do
you think mark
i get it my ex-girlfriend hate it when i
whistled
like i would whistle while i did [ __ ]
like
i'm mopping up she's like don't whistle
i hate whistling it annoys me and it was
weird cause i'm like does my own
girlfriend hate when i'm happy
that's what it felt like but she just
hated the whistling because it was
inconsistent
you know she couldn't concentrate but uh
i get it i get the humming but it
doesn't bother me but i get what he's
saying
i've never had a partner who does that
so i can't relate to it
uh but yeah noise random noise would
probably bother me
yeah yeah i totally understand it
especially in like close quarters
i could yeah i see that being an issue
i'm so scared of my partner or whoever
being upset that i'm like all right
she's humming
she's whistling great i'll take it i'll
take the annoying hum over
pissed off you know what that's a great
point
as long as as long as you're not furious
with me
yeah exactly let's [ __ ] dance
i'm in here here so yeah get on that
patreon
check out the email send us something
you hate you love you drinking you're
talking about
your recommendation and uh yeah keep
drinking and
leave us some reviews you guys have left
us such nice reviews on itunes wherever
you listen just keep leaving us five
stars we appreciate it
get on the patreon follow us uh you know
we might be
drunk on instagram follow mark and i
obviously on social media and uh
i'm doing a virtual gig march 22nd so
get tickets on my website
got bridgeport connecticut next month
got some other gigs coming up so
mark where are you going to be man
that's a decent room that bridgeport
i like it it's fun yeah i'm all alone i
chased off stage there once but
otherwise otherwise really
yeah yeah save that i'll save that for
another one yeah
uh i'm in lexington kentucky i've never
been to comedy
on broadway i love it really it's
fantastic yeah oh great
all right classic classic room oh great
all right columbus funny bone paramount
better
okay i got can i give you a quick
recommendation please i don't know if
keen uh if the keen raceway is going on
the racetrack there is fantastic
if not hit up a [ __ ] brewery man
that's all the bourbon's made
oh that's right i think that's a
distillery
distillery i'm a [ __ ] look i've had a
few of these drinks
i'm on threads here it's all the same
tacoma comedy club but goobies and you
know my goobies
yeah i love them hartford yeah spokane
uh virginia beach funny bone i've never
been that should be weird
portland helium this is all summer so
yeah just come on out check the websites
follow us on social media tell a friend
keep drinking
or keep not drinking and uh you know
enjoy your life folks yeah i think i got
arlington in
may i got atlantic city coming up i went
to virginia
atlantic city yeah i got some more
coming up and more will be added so
you know keep uh keep checking the
website we'll post about that [ __ ]
though but uh
keep telling your friends about this
pockets i feel like it's a great podcast
so i hope you're enjoying it
yes same here here
bottoms up